Disney executives are now reflecting on
why people don't like their movies
anymore specifically this movie light
year remember light year came out it was
the new Toy Story movie it completely
flopped and it was a movie that had a
lesbian kiss in it and where they
replaced Tim Allen one of the only
conservative actors in Hollywood they
replaced his voice and had some other
guy some lib Guy voice Buzz Lightyear so
here's what Disney said
we've done a lot of soul searching about
that because we all love the movie we
love the characters in the premise I
think probably what We've Ended on in
terms of what went wrong is that we
asked too much of the audience
that was Pixar's Chief creative officer
when they hear Buzz they're like great
where's Mr Potato Head and Woody and Rex
and then we drop them into this science
fiction film that they're like what even
if they've read the material on the
press it was just a little too distant
both in concept and I think in the way
that characters were drawn that they
were portrayed it was much more of a
science fiction
yeah maybe I don't know I think the
concept was pretty easy the concept was
Buzz Lightyear is a toy
and Buzz Lightyear is based on a movie
character so this is the movie
okay yeah maybe that won't be quite as
popular as Toy Story one of the most
popular
cartoon franchises of all time
but I get it that's fine I don't think I
don't think the audience is so stupid
that they couldn't get that concept
sci-fi is a very popular genre I don't
think it's that the audience just can't
get into sci-fi no it was the wokeness
guys it was the lesbian kiss and it was
the replacing the voice now some people
said well they had to replace the voice
because it's a different kind of
character
it's Buzz Lightyear the movie character
not Buzz Lightyear the toy
yeah it's a little too clever by half if
you ask me
because toys are just they just play
recordings of the movie characters
so if the joke is that the quality of
the toy is so low that the voice is
totally different it just doesn't play I
think they probably leaned into booting
Tim Allen because he's a conservative
and I think that the movie flopped
because it was woke and in the press it
was being portrayed correctly as woke
and then the audience didn't show up
it's not that complicated guys we talked
yesterday about the El Salvadoran
president
who had that wonderful video and this
incredible policy
where he's he's cut his murder rate by
58 in El Salvador by just locking up all
the criminals turns out it's really
simple you want to you want to cut the
murder rate lock up the murderers
it's really simple you want audiences to
go show up to your movies don't make
them these woke tedious lectures
give the audience what they want they're
going to show up to your movie speaking
of groomers like Disney Randy Weingarten
head of the teacher Union
is out doing what she does best which is
whining and screaming and trying to get
more money and power this time at the
Supreme Court because there is a
challenge to the Biden administration's
ability to to forgive student loans with
the stroke of a pen take a listen
this is what really pisses me off during
the pandemic we understood that small
businesses were hurting and we helped
them and it didn't go to the Supreme
Court to challenge it think businesses
were hurting and we helped them and it
didn't go to the Supreme Court to
challenge it all of a sudden when it's
about our students they challenge it the
corporations challenges the student loan
lenders challenge that that is not right
that is not fair and that is what we are
finding as well when we say castle soda
dead that was Randy Weingarten doing her
Howard Dean impression we're gonna whoa
not not very persuasive
and the rhetorical device she uses is
not very persuasive because what does
she say she says when it's about
forgiving money to businesses that's
fine
but when it's about our students
our why Randy Weingarten the woman who
wouldn't let our students back into
school for two years even though they
faced statistically pretty much zero
risk from the coronavirus but I didn't
want to do it because I insisted that my
union members get more time off and get
paid for it hi Randy Weingarten who care
about our students I want to make sure
they get their student loans forgiven
Randy Weingarten students
of which he has none she doesn't teach
any she doesn't actually have any
students she's a union boss
Randy weingarten's students though the
students that her members are teaching
don't have any student loans
they're public school students or high
school students
Middle School students Elementary School
students they don't have student loans
what is Randy Weingarten talking about
she's not at the Supreme Court
representing students
she's at the Supreme Court representing
her members
the teacher union members they're the
ones with the student loans
the student debt crisis rally in D.C
is to stop a court challenge to Biden
canceling ten thousand dollars in
federal student loans for individuals
making less than 125 000 per year or
households earning less than two hundred
fifty thousand dollars per year
annually as of 2020 and 2021
that describes the teacher union members
as always
the teacher Union is not about the
students
the teacher Union harms students
on pretty much every single front
the teacher Union exists not to help
students but to oppose students and to
support
the teacher union members they're the
ones that they're there for
we're going to support our students by
locking them out of school and saddling
them with even more debt
woo
so the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member use code knowleskin wlas a check
out for two months free on all annual
plans
[Music]
foreign